yeah we learn by doing
and so the cash flow bargain rich dad
poor dad the only book that covered the
three financial statements income
statement
balance sheet
statement of cash flow
those are the three things that count
and so when i walk into my banker today
like in 2008 when the whole thing
collapsed with layman and by the way i
was on cnn speaking to wolf blitzer
saying levin was going down wow
you know so i called that one because i
could see you can see it coming you know
and so i was on lehman i called it
coming down and all this stuff
but it's just a matter
of teaching you know all we have to do
is teach
but the teachers unions are in the way
and my poor dad guess what he was head
of
teachers union
people can ask me
how did you know how did my wife
she was 37 i was 47 when we retired so
how'd you guys do it and we couldn't
explain it to them because most people
went to school they learned go to school
get a job work hard save money get out
of debt and invest for the long term in
the stock market i do none of that i
don't have to any of that
so anyway we created the cash flow board
game it's the onl because maria
montessori was one of the great
entrepreneur i mean educational
entrepreneurs yeah she says what the
hand does the mind remembers now think
about this could you learn to play golf
reading a book
but that's what our schools are trying
to do so my wife and i in 1996
first created the cash flow board game
to teach the financial statement the
single most boring subject in schools
it's horrible
so we made it fun we made a game and all
this so income expense assets
liabilities cash flow those are three
main financial statements in a financial
statement income statement which is
income expense
balance sheet asset liability and thirds
of statement of cash flow that's what
the game is called cash flow
so i think
he hasn't agreed to yet but desantis is
considering
using our board game to teach financial
education because kim's like kids like
to play with games i did yeah i hated
lecture i hated it
how cool are you going to get a little
uh you get a little residual on that or
what
of course you're a capitalist i mean
come on
make it what what what a dang chao peng
sing get rich is glorious i agree with
him he's a communist but i agree
it's not bad do you happen to remember
there was a game back when i was a kid
so this was on the apple 2c before the
mac mac or the macbook or any of that
there was a game on apple 2c called
lemonade stand and that's what it was
you were running a little lame lemonade
stand there were no graphics it told you
the weather and how much sugar maybe you
should buy and how many people are out
on the street and and i learned a lot
from that actually yeah yeah we learn by
doing
and so the cash flow bargain rich dad
poor dad the only book that covered the
three financial statements income
statement
balance sheet
statement of cash flow
those are the three things that count
and so when i walk into my banker today
like in 2008 when the whole thing
collapsed with layman and by the way i
was on cnn speaking to wolf blitzer
saying levin was going down wow
you know so i called that one because i
could see you can see it coming you know
and so i was on lehman i called it
coming down and all this stuff
but it's just a matter
of teaching you know all we have to do
is teach
but the teachers unions are in the way
and my poor dad guess what he was head
of
teachers union
and if you study marx
his words were workers of the world
unite
and my father
and my rich dad you know this i was like
15 or 16. his workers were going out on
strike in hawaii
and rich dad called me he says would you
mind coming to manage you know maintain
one of our desks for us at night so i
said sure so i went down to help my rich
dad out by may just be a kid
managing the death so tourists could
check in and out
and i got home and my poor dad
gave me hell he says you're a scab yeah
i was just helping a friend out
but the teachers union as you know
they're as marxists as they come
workers of the world unite so that's all
in that's all in capitalist manifesto
they're just quotes
they're just quotes from stalin marx mao
and all those guys
we were warned but nobody paid attention
so how do what do you think the first
step in reversing that is if you were
talking to a 20 if there's a 21 year old
watching this show that's on the fence
maybe they just got out of school
although i know you would say they don't
have to go to school in the first place
but let's say they're 21 they're trying
to figure out what they're going to do
where they're going to live what kind of
life they want but they've been
indoctrinated with a certain amount of
that stuff what's the first way we can
get these people do you think i think i
think the first to do is question the
indoctrination
as thomas saul you know from stanford
says
it's not education it's indoctrination
go to school
what do you learn about money nothing
get a job who pays the highest taxes
workers
uh pay your taxes
rich don't pay taxes get out of debt
i'm a billion dollars in debt because in
1971 when nixon took the dollar off the
gold standard i said thank you jesus
i'm going to borrow my ass off now
and invest in the stock market i don't
invest in the stock market i'm not
saying you shouldn't
but having a rich dad having financial
education understanding financial
statements understanding cash flow gave
me freedom that most people will never
have because they've been indoctrinated
go to school get a job work hard save
money pay taxes get out of debt and
invest in the stock market i don't do
any of those things because i don't have
to
do you think there's a unique moment for
people to follow your path right now
because so many people kind of don't
trust the system right now they see that
oh they can just print money money's
worth less none of this really makes
sense there are no balance sheets so
more people might be willing to do some
of the non-traditional things that
you've been doing for 30 years wait more
than 30 years actually well i think you
said it earlier 10 years ago we couldn't
do this
that wasn't the zoom there wasn't any of
this you know this iphone here is the
most powerful entrepreneur tool ever saw
my whole life i can text anybody in the
world today
you know i can go on youtube but you can
have your own podcast
it's so powerful but if your brain isn't
a capitalist brain you use it
to watch kitty porn or whatever people
do today you know what i mean it's like
it's did you it's also destroying our
society this iphone
that's my concern so that's why you know
i like trump and desantis
and i'm voting for financial education
because that's where capitalism begins
capitalism gives us more freedom and
that's all i fight for freedom
you know that when when covet came out
they took away our freedom of speech
now they're going to wear a second
amendment the guns
disarm the police whatever they're
talking about defund the police it's all
marx
you know his mouth mouth says politics
comes with the barrel of the gun
it's all there it's it's in it's in this
book here it's all let me read you what
what nikita khrushchev said in 1959
your children's children will live under
communism you americans are so gullible
no you won't accept communism overnight
but we will keep feeding you small doses
of socialism
until you'll finally wake up and find
out you already have communism that's
what we're finding out today that we
already are communists
we will not have to fight you
we will so weaken your economy until you
fall like over ripe fruit into our hands
nikita kusha september 29
1959 and i don't know jim records just
made an announcement
that the uh biden just signed into
executive order something that cbdc
central bank digital digital currency
we're now 100 communists
biden just cited on march 6 2022.
we're officially communist now because
he took control of our money central
bank digital currency is a spy system
it's spyware
it'll control our entire lives
so i would i would check out jim records
is a good friend of mine one of the
smartest guys i know
but today we must be cautious who our
sources of information are as you know
and jim records jim records is on the
pulse of it right now central bank
digital currency is 100 communist if
you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about politics
instead of non-stop yelling check out
our politics playlist and if you want to
watch full interviews on a variety of
topics watch our full episode playlist
all right over here and to get notified
of all future videos be sure to
subscribe and click the notification
bell